is there a rule by the way you know like
you hear that like fists or if you're a
professional fighter it's it's actually
illegal to fight or what are the rules
as far as like hey by the way I'm a
professional UFC fighter one of the
greatest of all time are there
disclaimers you have to give what are
the rules of fighting normal citizens uh
you know I do know that once you do
fight you are considered a weapon in
court I had that in Holland I had a guy
who at the party started knocking out
women and then he was my ex-bought in
the Lord knocked him out knocked her out
too so I grabbed him I said let's go
find a tree outside because I saw there
was something wrong with him he was
foaming on their mouth he had like a
delirium
so I'm walking outside with them and
while I'm walking outside there's this
old guy sitting I was retired it was a
party from a company young was his name
and he knocked that guy out also so now
I start pushing him hard outside I said
let's pick up a tree and I push him away
and right away his son-in-law's behind
me and they're both attacking me and
this was a week before I had a fight a
Thai boxing match and it was literally
uh I swear I go bang bang if I was over
and I and I look at my wife and I go
like I guess I've been shaved for next
week right
and then the guy got up and I heard him
scream and I turned around and he came
running at me and I kick but because he
came in I didn't hit with my foot hit it
with my shin in the face
and that was bad I mean broken skull
teeth all out broken jaw it was it was
like scary you know and then of course
the police came
but you know I had all these Witnesses
he was beating women so it was okay but
I had to go to court for that one and
then that state so then you know you're
you can't fight again because you're
known as you have a weapon or no no no
no no you can in in self-defense you
can't it's like when you're carrying a
weapon you know in self-defense for your
life or somebody you love you're allowed
should
got it so I guess I know what you're
asking because you've heard about it
before where you know this person is a
registered if he fights he goes to just
bunch of [ __ ] man that's not a true
no I had to skip for movies I had this I
had to you know register register my
hands lightning and thunder over here
this guy this I'm sitting in the in the
in a pla on a plane and the Stuart the
lady female comes to me says I hear you
a fighter and I go yeah yeah okay and
she's come with me as like very
secretive and I'm standing uh where
where they stand nowhere and she goes to
me you know I have a friend of mine he
had to register so I register his hands
as weapons
she gave me a card she says here watch
it I said now I don't need that card and
she says why I go you know that's
complete BS right you can't you can't do
that no no Lucas registerhands.com I go
oh he started the company so you can say
it's like buying a black belt at
blackbelt.com you know I go this is
completely bull it's it it's really not
it but you are considered a weapon
though once you're in jail or in jail in
court that's what they say you're
considered a weapon once you're in court
or hurting somebody for for fighting
because with me they said would you say
that you would hit harder than somebody
uh else I mean you're an athlete I go
you mean like a shot boot guy or a
tennis player I think they hit as hard
as I do you know so because they really
wanted to steal to martial arts I said
come on now you know I was just
defending myself and she was okay it was
a female judge I remember a smirk on her
face why I saw your thing on Sports
Science did you see that Pat yeah that
was insane
or the liver yeah exactly where they
basically there's a show on ESPN called
Sports science which by the way I loved
it I don't know why they went away with
it it was a very good show they would do
you would make you see the science of
yeah what a human specimen certain
people were yeah that one right there
yeah you can't play it obviously no no
that's for the spleen exactly the one
that I really liked was the the crash
test dummy because that's where I I
tripled all the other Fighters had to
kick it and I was so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
bright Tori or future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]